[Musique]
alors pour commencer je vais demander à
une personne sur deux de se lever dans
la salle
un peu de sport une personne sur deux
selon l'organisation mondiale de la
santé une personne sur deux vivra un
traumatisme au cours de sa vie et la
moitié d'entre elles sera polytraumatisé
donc à vous de voir les personnes
assises ou les personnes debout
je vous laisse y réfléchir vous pouvez
vous rasseoir alors ses premiers
chiffres sont déjà effrayant mais c'est
peut-être pire si l'on considère la
question de l'enfance en danger en
france selon les associations de
protection de l'enfance
on estime qu'un enfant sur dix est en
danger en france ou si vous voulez deux
enfants par classe de 20 dans chaque
classe à l'école
ces chiffres il devrait nous alerter sur
l'urgence à agir pour ces adultes en
devenir qui sont aujourd'hui les copains
d'école de vos enfants
je suis docteur en sciences humaines
c'est à dire que j'ai réalisé une thèse
en sciences humaines avec six femmes est
la particularité de ces femmes et
qu'elles ont été toutes des petites
filles maltraitées
pourtant elles ont réussi à s'en sortir
à rebondir dans la vie à s'autoriser un
avenir meilleur et c'est ce que l'on
appelle la résilience
alors comment est ce que j'ai réalisé ma
thèse donc six années de co-construction
avec ces femmes à travers 60 heures
d'entretien de récits de vie
scrupuleusement analysés au mot près
c'est ce que l'on appelle la clinique
dialogique c'est la méthodologie
développée par martine la vie belle ma
directrice de thèse
alors vous vous demandez peut être
comment est-ce qu'on entre en résilience
alors selon boris cyrulnik le père de la
résilience en france le meilleur moyen
pour rebondir après un traumatisme c'est
de mobiliser le souvenir que l'on a de
l'attachant secure que l'on a développé
avec sa mère quand on était enfant dans
les premiers mois de la vie plus
simplement l'amour que l'on reçoit dans
la petite enfance nous façonnent et nous
sécurise pour toute la vie
alors du coup je me suis demandé comment
font les enfants qui n'ont pas la chance
d'avoir été nommés par leurs parents
est-ce qu'ils sont condamnés au malheur
comment on fait les femmes avec
lesquelles j'ai travaillé pour s'en
sortir pour rebondir
alors ces femmes leur parcours je vous
en dire quelques mots maya 40 ans
abandonnée à la naissance adoptée par
une première famille puis par une
seconde parce que la première la
maltraite
à 17 ans elle devient maman parce
qu'elle veut se reconstruire sa propre
famille elle s'en sort également grâce à
l'école elle devient aide soignante
véronique 35 ans une maman alcoolique et
dépressive un père manipulateur et un
quotidien rythmé par les violences
verbales physiques et sexuelles elle est
aujourd'hui maman de deux enfants grâce
à un compagnon bienveillant nathalie 55
ans enfant abusé pendant huit ans à la
pourtant essayé de parler mais quand
elle a tenté parler de dire ce qui se
passait sa parole a été refusée elle
était niée arrête de faire des histoires
pour rien avec tes histoires de touche
pipi
arrête de [ __ ] la merde dans ta
famille avec dans la famille avec tes
histoires
elle s'en sort grâce à la psychologie et
la psychanalyse sophie 50 ans a cru
mourir de la violence de ses parents
mais c'est l'amour des mots qui lui a
permis de rebondir
elle est devenue prof de français mais
la résilience pour autant c'est pas
magique
à 34 ans son processus est attaqué par
un cancer
son corps parle sepsi lui dira même
qu'elle fait un cancer mammaire et
pourtant son corps va finir par an créé
la résilience tout va s'arranger elle va
guérir et aujourd'hui tout va pour le
mieux
elle est heureuse et amoureuse sans dia
35 ans né de père inconnu comme ses
frères et soeurs ex positionnement par
sa mère à des agressions sexuelles
elle s'en sort grâce à l'islam qui va
apaiser ses idées suicidaires
elle s'en sort également grâce à l'école
elle devient orthophoniste et maître de
conférences en sciences du langage
enfin anne 50 ans une maman
maniaco-dépressive un mariage forcé elle
se sauver et rencontre quelqu'un d'autre
malheureusement cet autre homme se
révèle particulièrement violent et
particulièrement pendant la grossesse de
sa fille qui est polyhandicapée
aujourd'hui elle arrive à se sauver pour
autant et elle reprend des études de
psycho est aujourd'hui à la rencontre et
à un compagnon bienveillant qu'elle
appelle son gandhi
toutes ces femmes s'en sont sortis
toutes ces femmes sont entrées en
résilience donc la résilience est un
processus à mai au développement à
mettre en oeuvre à faire émerger qui va
vous permettre de vous autoriser un
avenir meilleur et de rebondir est ce
que j'ai découvert en tant que chercheur
avec ses six femmes au cours de ces six
années c'est que ces six femmes n'ont
pas développé un seul processus de
résilience mais quatre le premier c'est
la résilience colère c'est à dire que
quand elle était petite fille elles ont
surinvesti l'école jusqu'à devenir des
élèves modèles en plus les preuves les
aimait beaucoup
il leur apporte est l'affection l'amour
qu'elle n'avait pas de leur famille ces
profs étaient leurs tuteurs de
résilience alors un tuteur de résilience
c'est quoi un tuteur de résilience et la
personne qui est là pour vous quand vous
en avez besoin
qui vous dit je crois en toi ensuite à
l'adolescence deuxième forme de
résilience la résidence sociale leurs
amis leurs copines leur groupe de pairs
sont venus constitué constituer une
deuxième famille un peu plus tard à
l'âge adulte
fortes de leur résilience scolaire elles
ont développé des carrière hors norme
donc là vous allez me dire bon bah
finalement tout va bien c'est pas si
simple
parce que sur le plan affectif notamment
ces femmes ont eu du mal à développer
des relations de couple saine et
équilibrée
le problème qui persiste a en fait
c'était leur mère qui était toujours
présente et qui continuait de chosifier
leur fille comme des souffre-douleur
mais un jour ces femmes réussissent
enfin à se défaire de cet attachement
toxiques avec leur mère et elle
rencontre un compagnon bienveillant donc
vous aurez compris je suis passionné par
la résilience et par ces femmes
courageuses
mais pourquoi est ce que je me suis
intéressé à la baisse à la thématique de
la résidence alors à 18 ans j'étais
suivi par une psychologue qui m'a parlé
de la résilience à propos de mon
parcours et elle m'a conseillé d'aller
lire boris cyrulnik
alors je me souviens être allé acheter
mon premier livre de boris cyrulnik
celui là même les vilains petits canards
j'ai suivi les conseils de loppsi 1 donc
elle me dit de lire j'ouvre le livre je
commence
j'ai rien compris j'ai rien compris je
suis resté totalement hermétique
j'ai peut-être vaguement saisi que le
type avait l'air sympa avec les gens qui
avait galéré
malheur au delà de ça je suis resté
sécurité totalement hermétique la
résilience est resté dans la caisse des
trucs d'intellectuels pourtant six
années plus tard peu près au cours de
mes études
le concept ressort c'est à dire je suis
arrivé en master on me demande de
choisir un sujet de recherche et là je
sais pas je contrôle rien il ya le
brésilien ce qui sort de ma bouche et en
plus mon sujet de recherche est acceptée
et alors peut-être que peut-être même
pire que tout ma directrice de mémoire
est une amie de boris cyrulnik et elle
me dit qu'elle le fait venir à nantes 15
jours plus tard donc je me retrouve avec
un sujet de mémoire que je ne connais
absolument pas j'ai 15 jours pour aller
creuser la question est là donc pendant
quinze jours je fais le marathon de la
résilience je lis absolument tout ce que
je trouve sur la résilience
voilà une petit à petit exemple est au
bout des 15 jours je comprend enfin ce
que voulait me dire même s'il met 18 ans
le jour j de la rencontre avec boris
cyrulnik à rim
donc j'ai préparé deux trois phrases
hyper ciselé pour dire merci à boris
cyrulnik et lui dire à quel point ce
qu'il avait écrit compta et prenez sens
pour moi par rapport à mon parcours 1
j'arrive avec ma superbe pile de livres
à 2000 cassé et j'arrive devant lui et
là je me mets à pleurer c'est terrible
je me le ciel je me repens c'est
lamentable
et comme il est hyper gentil il me
rattrape et plus il me rattrape et plus
je pleure enfin bref c'est pathétique
en rentrant chez moi le soir je me
demande un peu je suis curieuse j'ai
attendu d'être chez moi pour regarder la
dédicace et puis en fait quand je rentre
chez moi je me suis rendu compte qu'il y
en a pas dédicacé il les a tous
dédicacé pour dire à quel point j'ai
pleuré longtemps six années plus tard
c'est la soutenance de ma thèse dans le
jury boris cyrulnik est présent il
valide la thèse et au delà de la
visitation de la thèse il valide aussi
le processus de résilience de ces six
femmes etc était fondamentale pourquoi
parce qu'en fait ces femmes
aucune d'entre elle est allée porter
plainte aucune d'entre elles n'était
allé devant la justice alors que
l'institution universitaire
reconnaissent les faits dont elle avait
été victime
ça a été essentielle et ça évidemment
participer à ce processus de résilience
mon message aujourd'hui en tant que
psychologue engagé il est sous forme
d'une double invitation
la première c'est d'inviter toutes les
personnes qui font face à des
difficultés dans la vie a osé demander
de l'aide pour les aider à rebondir et
la deuxième invitation c'est pour tout
le monde en fait je voudrais inviter
toutes les personnes a osé se
positionner en tant que tuteur de
résilience pour aider les autres à s'en
sortir et si j'ai accepté de participer
à 6 ce soir personnellement cette fois
c'est parce qu'en fait moi aussi j'en
suis passé par là
comme ces six femmes alors mon but ce
soir c'est pas de dévoiler sur ce que
j'ai vu dans mon enfance je pense même
que c'est pas l'essentiel l'essentiel en
fait je pense que c'est pas tellement ce
que l'on vit je pense que c'est tout ce
que l'on en fait l'essentiel c'est pas
les difficultés les traumatismes
l'essentiel c'est comment on va les
transformer comment est-ce qu'on va les
sublimer et si je m'en suis sorti parce
que clairement personne n'est condamné
âme au malheur tout le monde peut s'en
sortir et si je m'en suis sorti c'est
absolument pas parce que je suis plus
forte une autre martin danny bell il dit
même que la résilience c'est la force
des faibles alors peut-être que ma force
c'est est d'accepter ma vulnérabilité
peut-être que ma force ça a été
d'accepter la main tendue de tous les
tuteurs de résilience qui ont été kiki
que j'ai croisés sur mon chemin et qui
ont cru en moi
alors après ça n'a pas été facile tous
les jours non plus hein il ya eu des
hauts il ya eu débat mais je peux pas
non plus vous cacher que je suis hyper
fier de mon parcours hyper fier de mon
travail de thèse et si je m'en suis
sorti c'est évidemment parce que j'ai
été bien entouré
mais je pense que c'est aussi parce que
je me suis autorisé à croire en mes
rêves je vous remercie
[Musique]